in other news officials say many people
in northern california's wine country
are now suffering from
fire fatigue in the desperate struggle
to control the flames
the fourth major wildfire in three years
is spreading in the hills north of
san francisco the glass fire has burned
dozens of homes
and threatens thousands of others it's
one of nearly 30 fires burning in the
state
where this year's wildfires have burned
almost 25 times as much land
as last year jonathan vigliotti is in
calistoga california
where all 5 thousand people have been
told to evacuate
good morning to you high humidity
overnight has helped calm down the
flames giving fire crews who are already
stretched in
a bit of an upper hand here still the
glass fire only stands at 2 percent
contained
and a high wind event is expected
the fast-moving glass fire continues to
burn through the world famous napa
valley
destroying dozens of homes and
businesses and threatening
hundreds more more than 80 thousand
people have been forced to flee
including the entire towns of california
your house going am i ever going to see
it again some of the region's historic
wineries and vineyards have suffered
millions of dollars in damage
[Music]
fire crews attacked the flames from
above
but on the ground law enforcement
officers and homeowners are getting
desperate
a sheriff's lieutenant used a garden
hose to protect this house
i just had to do something and bob
hagrim saved his neighbor's home
quickly notifying firefighters after it
was nearly engulfed in flames in our
report yesterday morning
crews who are already stretched in cut
off the front steps
just in time that's it you know they
that's the whole thing
they're overwhelmed there's
it's crazy i've never seen anything like
it
this is the fourth major fire in this
area in three years
a 2017 fire here killed 22 people
douglas and john rumrall have evacuated
now twice
you feel so isolated and out of control
nothing you can do
and it's just nice to have people around
you that are caring
and it means everything
at least 29 people have died so far this
year in california
here at the glass fire hundreds of
structures have burned
and that number is likely to grow back
to you
those pictures jonathan please be
careful out there and thank you very
much